will smith's road to oscar just got a
bit clear what a night at the sag awards
welcome to entertainment tonight such a
great night 15 years after will's first
sag nomination he nabbed his first actor
for king richard and i spoke to him just
moments after his emotional win
[Music]
will smith
will smith yes they showed in the
audience denzel jumped on his feet and
was like clapping and cheering for you
denzel is always one of my first calls
when stuff's not going right it's a good
speed dial to have he just hugged me and
then he grabbed a weight off of his
shoulders and said you got it
i felt like you were on the verge of
emotion all night every time they showed
you you were almost there it's just
all of these
women
you know that
see you get me started
will got all choked up and wiped away
tears after his win he explained to me
why his role as the father of tennis
legends venus and serena williams is so
meaningful it's all these black women
that i get to
protect and
shine a light on
will and wife jada shared this sweet
kiss backstage she also supported her
man with her fashion but kinda by
accident now i didn't know that he was
wearing yeah yeah no this worked out
no it just so happened we looking like
them old people
that got a camper and just driving
across country with the matching
sweatsuits
more sag awards couples naomi watson
double nominee billy crudup made their
red carpet debut the two were rumored to
have been dating since 2017. naomi's
aussie bestie nicole kidman shared this
adorable moment with husband keith urban
inside keith was on one side and on the
other nick's movie husband from being
the ricardo's javier bardem
as for benefer the couple we were hoping
to see but didn't e.t has learned
nominee ben affleck skipped the awards
show for his son's 10th birthday party
on saturday there was more family time
ben and jlo were spotted at a bowling
alley with her kids
but the sag awards was date night for
others including tim mcgraw and faith
hill jason ritter with his wife
yellowjackets star melanie linsky and
kirsten dunst with fiance and the power
of the dog co-star jessie plemmons
kirsten lost in her category to west
side stories ariana dubose who gave gaga
this sweet shout out hi lady gaga you're
amazing she has a very intense stare so
it's really hard to not
acknowledge the intensity radiating off
of that human i love her music and her
artistry so it was an honor
[Music]
it really was a big night for gaga even
though she didn't win
jessica chastain
[Music]
yeah the double nominee was first to
stand for lead actress winner jessica
chastain who is now viewed as an oscar
front runner i was like down in that
champagne i was like it's not gonna
happen
gaga made the rounds going from selena
gomez to nicole kidman to salma hayek
but she broke down in tears meeting
helen mirren
gaga had fun with her gucci man jared
leto but before the show even started
she had this surprise star is born
reunion
a beaming bradley cooper held gaga close
and proudly posed but they weren't the
only co-stars reuniting fitz and olivia
yeah i know the band's back together
should i read the nominees for ensemble
in a drama series no
it's handled it's handled
folks are going to be asking could some
reunion happen i got no answers for you
you know in our minds we never are apart
we all still are family you know
and these two took us right back to high
school lisa kudrow your roman michelle
girl it will be a reunion
you look cute i know thanks
we went like pink and blue like remy and
michelle's costumes
lisa kudrow and dolce and gabbana mir
servino and joaque murray were perfectly
in sync even recreating their movie
dance backstage
[Music]
april you know it's 25 years
of roping on the show
just can you even wrap your brain around
that no i can't i can't i mean then
again i have a daughter who's applying
to college right now so i can't i can't
wrap her head about that yeah it's crazy
[Music]
the guys from hamilton reunited opening
the show in the room where it happened
but not this winning comedy ensemble
juno was the only ted lasso cast member
who didn't appear virtually from london
as they gear up to shoot season three
winner jason sudeikis got choked up
taking home the male actor comedy series
award for the second year in a row
thanks to my kids and this chosen family
here so
thank you very much really appreciate it
[Music]
meanwhile the ensemble in a drama series
award went to
what's that like the moment you hear
succession what is that moment like it
feels like they're going to say squid
game
that's what it feels like while the hbo
series is all about dysfunctional
siblings vying for control of the family
business i was always stealing so i
could win stealing cheating a monopoly
come on come on in real life father of
two karen culkin told me he's a happy
uncle to brother mccauley and brenda
song's 10 month old son dakota did you
have a welcome to the dad club moment
with him no no there's nothing you can
do to really help just you're in the pit
enjoy it it's hard it's the best
succession season four is about to begin
production the show's patriarch brian
cox reacted to fans thinking that will
be it you know the fans out there are
kind of losing their mind well it's up
to the writers if he decides there's
more to be got out of it then we'll do a
fifth season korean phenomenon squid
game made history as the first
non-english language series to win
acting prizes lee
[Applause]
has it sunk in yet not yet
i think it's going to take a while
winner zhangjae lee's interpreter
explained his idea on bringing his dead
cast mates back next season i think i
want to go i like to go home now let's
hear the idea
so my idea is that maybe the masked men
took all of them and made sure they came
back to life
there is no word yet if and just like
that we'll come back for season two i've
changed my vote to undecided miranda's
professor karen pittman reacted to the
news she was supposed to be her love
interest you're feeling extra today
listen michelle i did not know that
nobody told me that i said come on that
could have been sexy y'all
even though the cast of yellowstone lost
the ensemble drama series award to
succession they're celebrating being
cable's most watched show and dropping
clues for what to expect next season
what can you tell me about season five
highly dysfunctional family you know
maybe the highlight is we get together i
don't know
put the knife down honey i literally
don't know we get the scripts as they
come in i think we start in the middle
of may i do know that the new season
will be split in two parts it's coming
and it's bigger than you imagine
moving on to some marvelous moments with
nominee andrew garfield he made his red
carpet debut with girlfriend of three
months model alyssa miller the source
tells et they bring out each other's
good sides and have a lot of fun andrew
also had a lot of fun recreating this
spider-man meme and he gave us the
behind the scenes scoop before we shot
anything we just did a photo shoot of
the three of us pointing to each other
[Music]
i think they must have got one
good shot because we were all just
cracking up so much we couldn't quite
contain ourselves
andrew even weighed in on this recent
claim made by tom holland i'm not going
to tell you who
but one of us has a fake in there soon
well i have no idea it's not not me so i
have no clue i don't think it's toby
i've seen toby's butt toby's toby's got
back the power of the dog nominee
benedict cumberbatch has doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness due out in
may conspiracy theorists are out they
are they're saying maybe
uh he's evil part of the illuminati i'm
just trying to pull faces as clues that
will then be churned over on the
internet
no i like yeah maybe who knows who knows
i do i know i will tell you this it is
it's a feast and it's uh it's got
everything it says in the title and a
lot more besides and here's a marvel
reveal from michael douglas the kaminsky
met the nominee who arrived with oldest
son cameron gave us this update on his
next movie with paul rudd just finished
up our third ant-man our third marvel
comic